can you draw a shape with four sides and
three corners this question baffles most
students and probably even more adults
we usually think about shapes as
polygons every polygon has the same
number of sides as it does Corners n
sides means N Corners so how are we
supposed to solve this
let's go back to a square which has four
sides and four corners it's almost
correct but we need to remove one corner
so why don't we literally break the
problem wide open
Eureka This shape has four sides and
three corners we can even rearrange the
sides into a more familiar shape that
you probably see every single day
if you face an impossible problem never
give up for the answer you seek may
already be inside of you